[Music]
uh-huh
reject nation I'm Greg Alba I'm John
Humphrey we're gonna watch today top ten
stars to destroy their careers on live
TV yet dumb Sun's up yeah this is a
tough war sir video Christopher men
named Eric horseman the one individual
in the world who has dare I say it's a
real rejects tattoo on his right butt
cheeks so happy he did that that's how
he gets a lot of gay action all right is
from watchmojo.com let's go into this
well that didn't go as planned
welcome to watchmojo.com 10 celebs who
ruin their careers on live TV stretch
lists we're taking a look at celebrities
who completely tarnished their careers
thanks to a controversial mistake or
decision on live television we're also
considering stars who made a comeback
after their TV fiasco
if you like what you're hearing be sure
to check out the full song at the link
below
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
doing the background vocals of his style
[Music]
number ten Janet Jackson is arguably the
biggest career ending controversy and
live TV history that's why it's number
ten eight when Justin ripped away her
costume and revealed her breasts this
was certainly not Jackson's fault but
everyone acted like it was there could
have been ways that I could have gone
about it I could have licked it handled
it better Hollywood all better stoned
her and pretended that she never existed
and her subsequent album and singles
were blacklisted from Radio even mega
conglomerates got in on the boycott with
an executive at Viacom stating that the
higher-ups are still pissed at her CBS
was fined five hundred and fifty
thousand dollars and then the NFL was
asked to refund the ten million dollars
that they had been given to the halftime
show sponsor
luckily the heat has been what and
Jackson was inducted into the Rock and
Roll Hall of Fame in 2019 no more not I
don't know about all that other crap
this rocket had a budding career on
Saturday Night Live in the early 80s oh
hey how's it going kind of a cross
between Chevy Chase and Bill Murray he
was one of the major players in the
1980-81 season and he became popular for
his impressions his recurring character
Phil lively and a regular segment called
the rocket report good evening I'm
Charles rocket with weekend of Brackett
unfortunately rocket dropped an f-bomb
during the February 21st 1981 episode
breaking strict broadcast standards
first time I've been shot in my life
know this along with the season of a
negative reputation and critical
reception Murphy yes termination and
while he found some success playing
comic foils in various nineties movies
he never quite rose above his status is
that yes what can we say Hollywood takes
swearing and nudity very seriously
aren't you gonna invite me in number
eight Fergie by 2018 she is already on
her way out of the mainstream limelight
the Black Eyed Peas were in the midst of
an extended hiatus and Fergie hasn't had
a top 20 single as a solo artist since
2007 loser oh yes this is our intro song
showdown unfortunately her performance
was a little shaky and inappropriately
sensual and many people in attendance
could barely contain their laughter
[Music]
riki became a viral national
laughingstock it served as the final
nail in Fergie's coffin and she hasn't
been heard from since she has number
seven Paula Deen beloved southern chef
Paula Deen found herself in hot water in
2013 when former employee Lisa Jackson
sued her for racial and sexual
discrimination
Paula's ition is quite appalling to say
the least african-americans and even
wanted to host a plantation-style
wedding for her brother complete with
the black servants during the deposition
Paula admitted to using the n-word in
the past further hurting her reputation
what do you say Oh II I said the n-word
in the privacy of my own home and
retelling the story of my husband I'm
sorry that's racist she then appeared on
today to smooth things over but only cry
she's worse by playing the victim when
the whole ordeal was said and done
Paula's best so are you here to express
what you just said or are you here to
stop the financial bleeding number six
Brian Williams from 1993 to 1999 Brian
Williams served as the weekend news
anchor on NBC Nightly News before being
promoted to head anchor in 2004 the
story actually started with a terrible
moment a dozen years back during the
invasion of Iraq when the helicopter we
were traveling in was forced down after
being hit by an RPG he held this
position until 2015 when he was brought
under fire for lying about an event that
occurred to him during the Iraq war
what what altitude were you hidden we
were only at a hundred feet doing a
hundred forward knots because we had
these massive pieces of bridge beneath
us on slings according
Williams a helicopter that he was riding
in was taken down by an RPG numerous
soldiers came forward and claimed that
Williams was never part of this a
mistake and recalling the events of 12
years ago I want to apologize I said I
was traveling in an aircraft that was
hit by RPG fire I was instead in a
following aircraft we all landed after
the ground fire incident and spent two
harrowing nights in a sandstorm
following this he was demoted to chief
anchor at MSNBC and his professional
credibility was permanently stained I
hope they know they have my greatest
respect and also now my apology number
five 2004 when a simple scream was all
it took to ruin a career forever for the
2016 elections and he would have done
that exact same speech the exact same
way under the exact same conditions I
don't think anybody would have paid any
attention to it whistle after coming in
third in the Iowa Democratic caucuses
Dean made an impassioned and
unpresidential speech that ended with
him pumping his fist and screaming yeah
this speech effectively ended his
presidential campaign and the speech and
The Scream were relentlessly mocked by
the media and late-night talk show hosts
it soon became known as the Dean scream
and some believe that the endless
coverage was a product of media bias
against the politician while Dean later
became the chair of the Democratic
National Committee his dreams of
becoming president were crushed forever
on that people what are you doing it's
gonna be won in Colorado Iowa
[Music]
[Applause]
number four Natalia Kills and Willy moon
in 2015
Teddy Sinclair then known as Natalia
Kills was serving as a judge of the New
Zealand version of the axe doctor
alongside her husband Willie moon
unfortunately both Natalia and her
husband were accused of bullying a
contestant named Jo Irvine more we're
joined by a showbiz commentator paid it
forward hey did the judges deserve to be
set yes absolutely
Natalia insulted him for dressing like
her husband despite it being a basic
haircut and suit and stated that she was
embarrassed to be in his presence
I am disgusted how much you have copied
my husband from the hair to the suit do
you not have any value or respect for
originality following that one compared
him to Norman Bates and Leatherface
calling him creepy and stating his
belief that Irvine was going to steal
someone's face and kill everyone in the
audience someone skin to your face and
then kill everybody in the audience you
know solid constructive criticism like
that that is so rude and quickly
reverted back to nobodies he ends up
winning just goes yet to suffer through
these two morons
number three Sinead O'Connor Sinead
O'Connor's career was auditive Leigh
blowing up in the late 80s and early 90s
in that time she released her double
platinum album I do not want what I
haven't got
and her single nothing compares to you
peaked at number one in 17 countries
however that all came crumbling down on
October 3rd 1992 when O'Connor appeared
on SNL while performing she ripped a
photo of Pope John Paul the second to
protest sexual abuse against children
within the Catholic Church and she soon
became a public enemy in the victory
oh nothing would be last number one and
while she every bad today number two in
1989 reached number one and was
certified six times platinum he also
received five straight top five singles
in the United States three of which
topped the chart however a huge hiccup
occurred on July 21st 1989 when a lot of
performance for MTV suffered a technical
malfunction the track began to skip
reviewing that singer Rob Pilatus with
lip-synching guavas prompted doubts
regarding the duo no album was released
in America that singer Charles Shaw
revealed that his work was being
credited to pilatus and fab morvan the
duo admitted to being frauds and Milli
Vanilli was no more loose on a recording
contract which we thought was to be seen
in Rankin yeah had a reputation for they
had a bad reputation for anomalies you
didn't no no I was 18 years old coming
from France my son a recording contract
that was in German I've never seen any
hell yeah love watching this and unlike
with Ms Jackson this one's all on you
Ashley while performing on SNL in 2004
Ashley accidentally revealed that she
was lip-syncing when the vocals two
pieces of me began to play in place of
those from autobiography
[Music]
not knowing what to do Ashley Paige and
leader blamed the band for playing the
wrong sonic so not only was she
lip-syncing on SNL which in itself is a
big no-no she proceeded to throw her
band under the bus except no one bought
this and Ashley's career was left in
tatters dear viewers that's in Studio
City where she missed traffic be sure to
check out the music video for it right
here
I've done at least five of those things
I'm always lip-syncing on this no two of
these I was very present for Janet
Jackson which is not a big deal and
Ashlee Simpson which I actually get in
defense of Ashlee Simpson her band's a
piece yeah maybe it was a backing track
maybe she was gonna sing over it one of
the few reality shows i hook i dicted to
for a little bit and I used to hang out
at a friend's place was the simple life
and the Ashlee Simpson show on the
Ashlee Simpson show they had all this
footage where she was backstage she was
supposed to sing live but she was coming
down with a cold and she was really sick
so they had to agree to the lips it you
know like this whole thing with there's
an SNL's not cool that's not the ones
who agreed to let her to ten you can't
just let someone go up there you know
the producers they have to be aware
they're gonna be lip singing you know
what I mean yeah you have a little
reduction but I guess it's just if
something goes wrong oh yeah yeah
no there was curly a failed
communication and I think anyone who
ever is caught lip-syncing even when we
know their lip singing the countless pop
stars who do these like crazy
choreography dances depends on the show
some shows demand it you know there are
a bunch of videos of different like rock
acts especially being told to lip-sync
or to play sync even just everyone and
then they just start messing around and
making it very clear that no one's
playing anything for real but with
Ashlee since that makes sense and also
I'm biased because I really like Ashlee
Simpson songs ideas you've heard more
than one of her songs yeah oh I like her
tough girl songs maybe yeah in the
kitchen in the boyfriend oh god some
great songs let's just turn this into a
naturally Simpson retrospective the
Janet Jackson one we were like little
kids when that happened and still
watching the Super Bowls like all right
like you could easily miss that I get
the controversy and how publicize it was
but I wasn't aware of how much she was
attacked and all the lawsuits that were
going on and the people asking for their
money back like that's insane to me
what are you so upset about chill out
yeah I wasn't surprised by the one fine
but especially liked to give us back
like ten million dollars for paying for
the halftime show like that's like whoa
anything that made the Super Bowl more
feel memorable it's a landmark moment
immediate left elevation to see how many
people tune in after getting waiting for
Jackson tune in the Super Bowl yeah I'm
waiting for another mistake kibo the
egos reserved a kidsong nipple for the
first time damn it what are we doing
realize like half of these are from an
SNL so there's the Charles rocket one a
Sinead O'Connor that was on SNL Oh si
now there's probably a whole list of
countless people who are banned for SNL
it's usually a guest who's messed up
yeah you know like oh they're not
invited back anymore for a cast member
to drop the f-bomb which everyone was
laughing but I'm sure more dads are like
so I would love to know his side of the
story of why he decided to do that if he
just thought it was a slipper if he or
if he was like getting back at someone
or if he was on the verge of being fired
or something like that you know what I
mean go out with a bang might as well
write as sometimes I feel like something
like that would enhance your career for
being edgy or something not even Eddie
Murphy slipped up like that the Sinead
O'Connor I'd never heard of this it's
been decades since that happened and he
for me I'm like even if that happened
today people would come to Carl's
Rockets defense like it's just an effort
let him go rehired Twitter he gets mad
Sinead O'Connor if he did that today oh
my god that would be horrendous so
amusing this was the most amusing
WatchMojo video I've ever stuck they've
delivered on every number here now one
of these was like boring at all Brian
Williams oh yes I remember that I made a
mistake in recounting my story I thought
I was in a helicopter that was hit by an
RPG 12-years like oh no no no yeah
that was just such a bummer cuz I was
like ah Brian Williamses pretty good
anchor but I just won fudge of the facts
man oh thanks for everything
how could he think he could get away
with that I have no idea he really
painted himself out to be that kind of
heroic journalist like a matter of the
field and look I almost died to cover
the news American people man I can never
trust that guy after that don't don't
watch MSNBC good news
never seen him Brian Williams aside even
notice image was tainted or anything
like that the feather that kept him on
at all is honestly really surprising to
me but then again you know we do have a
precedent you know as you get close for
or not even close at all whatever these
things I'm like I'm surprised oh wait I
just see remind myself there's a
president now Saint Erica and he would
still be President and yeah he would be
able to sell that I didn't realize this
Ferdie recording moment his live
performance is the thing that seemed
like her career was ready on a downslope
and this just put the nail in the coffin
yeah it had been a while since she had a
new solo material hit and anything with
the black-eyed peas and he acting rules
you know I mean she just tried she was
trying yeah I mean I'll give it to her
that she made it her own I'm always a
little taken aback when people try to
pop up or jazzy or sexy up the anthem
cuz I'm just like that's not why any of
us are singing this song Hey when they
created the national anthem
it was meant for people the consulate
it's like a star it's it's a vocal riff
yeah it's made for vocal riffing it's
public domain yeah they're able to put
their own spin on it as much as they
want yes so do as many vocal runs as you
can over as many of those melodies as
possible easiest laughs we ever gotta -
mode out man
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Gregg doesn't have a shirt on we had to
do is go funny they are we're choosing a
song that's right man hey Fergie had
milk money she she's doing anything his
career exactly I don't understand how
did I miss something I think they just
felt it uncouth for him to be like you
know like Han duck doesn't befitting of
a president I have no idea like it's
it's the stupidest one I feel like out
of this list it's a few seconds of a
vocal Isaiah I'm not saying the
WatchMojo blessed is bad the idea that
this ruined his career which is true is
like yeah it's dumb silly to me
ridiculous it shows you now remind you
we have a president who if he did that
people would just do it right back just
take on that slope he's different he's
not a politician
Gregg Jong keep politics out of the
video where you had politics in the
video you're reacting your politics out
of my politics new politics out of it
that just shows how silly we judge these
people sometimes yeah I was I kept
looking for okay once again it's just
that just cuz he had a goofy scream
that's in the Dean scream it was it was
famous for that one campaign window I
never heard that scream that's when they
put it over Tom Cruise and The Mummy
falling out of the plane yeah I remember
it now that should be the new Wilhelm
scream mmm-hmm X Factor judges oh god
these are the only ones that pissed me
off yeah I've never actually seen like
I've seen mishaps happen on TV I feel
like I've seen a lot of them on SNL
who've never just people's straight up
belittling somebody and bullying them on
stage I did not understand that maybe we
didn't hear the whole clip yeah I was
this before after the guy sang or did
whatever he was there to do I mean they
usually don't speak until after the
person saying it yeah still though like
to attack what looks just like a generic
white guy guy with a regularly tight
haircut in a suit like he doesn't have
control over his head shake
I would love to hear what triggered them
so much to insult them to disagree he
literally did nothing but look normal
who was pops I know that was so weird I
couldn't wrap my brain even the crowd
was like getting pissed at them that
made me mad I'm like how could you
belittle someone like that to that
degree yeah and the guy looked like he
was feeling pretty terrible but he was
he was a lot of people don't feel like
they're good-looking and and then to be
attacked for your looks on live
television
yeah when you dress nice to be they
probably styled you on the way out like
it's not even about that I know that is
so ridiculous all I can think of is that
maybe it came back around for that guy
where people were like you know what
that was messed up and now we're gonna
embrace you or something like maybe the
public stepped in and gave that guy a
hug this uh Milli Vanilli store oh my
god did you know about the truth this is
one of the most famous lip-synch mishaps
of all time no but the truth that they
didn't even sing I didn't realize
completely that it was two complete
other singers I think that was the foggy
detail I mean I knew they had a big
lip-syncing scandal and that they
weren't fully responsible for the music
I didn't realize that they didn't even
sing at all that is one of the biggest
frauds I've ever heard
scams and music history they got the
French guy they were interrupting it
seemed like heartbroken by that well
yeah he said he was like we were young
and we signed these contracts that we
didn't even know how to read and I just
want to see that contract was the point
of this group to have like two guys come
in and sing over somebody else's
complete composition your voice is
stolen and you can't even speak up about
it that is so crazy to me I don't know
how you can live with yourself you know
the movie yesterday which is about a guy
who wakes up in a world where the
Beatles own existence and he starts
remaking the Beatles songs and clearly
that gets to him if you just watch the
trailer yeah
this is worse than that caveat is just
original that is some weird simulate
like I yeah I don't even know what to
make up I don't know how these artists
contain like what if they're asked to
perform like with the route friends or
that's like Jesus Christ that they're
just everything so humble to the point
that they always wriggle at it they keep
the money oh gosh I have no idea their
contract probably burned up quick at
least well this was a great list this
WatchMojo list really delivered I am I
like to watch more videos like this you
guys it's kids subscribe to
watchmojo.com oment so you wish were on
here that should be on here
comment below Eric thank you my dude for
sending this over Eric's my dude thank
you I am so happy that for the first
time in a long time you've requested a
video that can actually go up on YouTube
yeah it has the potential to be monetize
no mutilation no material it's been a
while cuz you like the shock videos and
while this was shocking in a different
way
clearly you took us into consideration
here buddy
and I appreciate that I hope you're
enjoying all the impossible meats that
you can heat I hope when you bite into a
burger you go that's not possible
you should get powdered a live
television oh oh yeah yeah I think that
would be a good idea is like skip the
the the leaking your sex tape and just
get it out to everybody in real time
it's perfect mmm say that word which one
STX oh I'm sorry do your you already
love set it oh yeah we can't cut it out
I forgot yours
[Laughter]